là avec le petit déjeuner est le repas
le plus important de la journée
oui parce que je suis du matin moi je
tourne des vidéos le matin j'aime bien
ça ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on n'a
pas parlé de photos et s'attendent quand
même assez bien parce que ma aujourd'hui
on va parler de retouches photo
justement retouches sur smartphone en
plus le coup non le shass une
chocolatine un pain au chocolat je
n'existe pas chocolatines les mecs
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravie comme à chaque fois
de vous retrouver de plus en plus
nombreux sur cette chaîne est
aujourd'hui on va parler
photo et instagram et plus précisément
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un certain
type de retouche qui est hyper populaire
en ce moment et on va donc voir comment
on peut passer de ça à ça et puis en
parlant d' instable vous pouvez me
suivre je vous mets le nom de mon
instinct c'est l'oeil dans la boîte je
mets plein de trucs assez sympa et puis
j'ai découvert comment marcher les
stories donc vous avez un petit peu de
making of des vidéos de tout donc bah
suivez moi sur un stade il ya le lien
dans la description mais juste avant de
commencer
attention quoi je fais ça avec mon
attention attention j'ai des choses à
vous dire avant ceux d'édith dont on va
parler cette façon de retoucher les
photos elle est jolie elle est sympa
aller à la mode et tout et tout mais
mais mais mais mais mais mais mais mais
mais je recommande de pas en abuser non
plus pour plusieurs raisons alors c'est
vous qui avez compte instagram qui sont
entièrement
retouché avec s'était dit là et c'est
clair qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont complètement happé par ce
look mais il ya fort à parier qu'en même
que d'ici quelques temps ce look sera
passée de mode
et que voit il ya aussi moyen de faire
plein de trucs avec les autres couleurs
genre y'a pas que le orange dans la
ville et j'entends tout un éventail de
couleurs sympathique et très joli et qui
peuvent offrir de belles photos donc moi
j'utilise cette élite mais
ponctuellement un bas sur toutes les
photos de temps en temps ça fait
toujours un petit truc un peu sympa un
peu jolie et pour finir n'y a pas juste
une seule façon de le faire ça c'est ma
vision des choses
tu aurais pu en avoir plein d'autres
alors ce look qu'on va appeler désaturer
contraste et on le retrouve depuis un
petit moment chez des gens comme ça me
colle d'heure qui ont popularisé un
petit peu ce ce look est il et on va
dire dans l'esprit à mi chemin entre le
noir et blanc est l'outil le nom orange
parce que on va avoir un côté très
désaturer bas loin du noir et blanc on
va garder quand même juste les tons de
pau et le thi lan orange voilà
semble-t-il en fait juste le orange et
c'est tellement simple affaire que je me
suis dit qu'on allait carrément faire la
retouche au smart phone voilà avec un
iphone ou un android ou tout ce que vous
voulez mais on utilisera l'application
lightroom
parce que je sais pas vous mais moi
j'adore retouchée sur l'iphone en fait
c'est le truc que tu as dans la poche et
on n'a pas le même grand écran qu'on
pourra avoir sur une tablette ou sur un
ordinateur mais ça sympa de pouvoir
éditer comme ça la volée plutôt que de
soit 36 croche allait souffler pas plus
attendre c'est parti
retouchant cette petite photo alors
première chose on va s'attaquer à la
lumière on va améliorer un petit peu
l'exposition parce que là du coup il ya
des choses à retravailler avant
d'attaquer la couleur alors pour ça je
vais aller cliquer sur le bouton lumière
on va remonter un petit peu parce que
notre photo elle est légèrement sous aix
et est par définition vu qu'on veut du
contraste et augmenter un petit peu le
contraste là ok encore un peu plus très
bien on va aller aussi rendre les noirs
un tout petit peu plus dark
voilà là on est pas mal en termes de
lumière on reviendra dessus après
maintenant on va s'occuper de la couleur
alors vu qu'on veut désaturer ben on va
enlever la saturation sur pas mal de
couleur pour ça on va aller sur le
mélangeur ici
et on va aller sélectionner le vert on
n'envoie pas le sien on n'en veut pas
non plus le bleu non plus le violet il
dégage et ce géo les rose clair y dégage
aussi quoique pas tant que ça voilà up
ensuite les rouges on va les teintes et
un petit peu en orange
le jaune on va le dé saturer un petit
peu mais pas trop là est déjà là on a
une différence qui est quand même assez
importante
voyez tout le vert qui a dégagé derrière
par exemple on est bon alors s'être
touche de couleur elle va mettre en
valeur le teint de peau elle va avoir un
côté un petit peu adouci sans un petit
peu bonne mine
ensuite la dernière étape ça va être la
finition est là c'est un petit peu à
l'appréciation de chacun là c'est une
histoire de goût moi je vais vous
montrer comment chauffer mais vous
n'êtes pas obligé de faire pareil alors
on va monter un tout petit peu la
température l'a ensuite on va aller dans
effet on va rajouter un petit peu de
vignettes jeu mais pas trop pour donner
un effet un petit peu dramatique
moi j'aime bien la clarté aussi au plat
voilà comme ça ça donne un effet un
petit peu patiné un petit peu brillant à
la photo qui est assez sympa et juste
pour finir on va retourner dans lumière
on va aller dans le coup on va donner un
tout petit effet un peu vintage en
remontant la voilà pas trop sinon ça
fait tout much
en remontant les noirs ici et
éventuellement recontre à c'était un
tout petit peu mais vraiment un tout
petit peu ici notre photo et on clique
sur terminer et c'est pas plus compliqué
que ça avant après alors le truc qu'on
peut pas faire sur smartphone mais qu'on
peut faire sur la version ordi de
lightroom s'est créé des prêts s'est tu
quand vous avez terminé votre est dit
ici vous pouvez enregistrer sous forme
de prêt cet été y donner un nom pour
pouvoir le réutiliser plus facilement
après d'ailleurs j'ai créé un pack de
près cette que je vais vous proposer
très bientôt alors je sais pas encore
exactement comment j'ai pas envie de le
vendre je suis en train de réfléchir à
une solution un petit peu alternative 10
à 12 ans
dirait un peu plus dans les prochaines
vidéos et puis ben n'arrivait à la fin
enfin presque à la fin parce que les
vrais abonnés ceux qui savent les gens
bien savent qu'à la fin enfin fin de la
vidéo il ya toujours un petit truc en
plus pour vous qu'est cadeau donc les
amis comme d'habitude bien sûr n'hésitez
pas si cette vidéo vous a plu à m un
énorme coup de blaster sur le pouce en
l'air sur la cloche sur le bouton
s'abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait sur
le bouton partager aussi c'est cool ça
fait toujours plaisir et moi je vous dis
comme d'habitude rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
profite alors pour une fois pas de
blague à la fin juste pour vous dire que
je réfléchisse fortement à fermer mon
tipi parce que j'aime beaucoup le
concept de youtube qui permet aux
abonnés de financer la chaîne sans
dépenser un centime juste vous cliquez
sur le lien ici vous regardez une pub de
30 secondes ça fait cinq centièmes pour
billy donc le badge ou recommande
d'aller faire un petit tour sur youtube
parce que comme ça peut-être en dessous
je pourrais être à 100% sur youtube
s'est jamais faire plein de vidéos
encore plus plus régulièrement grâce à
vous ça serait cool et bisous lamy